that's saturday I won't be responsible
for providing for my wife especially
sexually well I'm not really worried
about the last month Corey is the best
wedding planner in Atlanta so what
you're going to do not intimidated by
you I'm stepping up the speed was a fan
or all the new dealers in Atlanta are
getting supplied through Antonio Pope in
Miami you need to get me something on
this guy two days tops he'll get a team
together and fix this put me in on a
James i'm like half cop half Puma I'll
get in your ass uh-oh the
brothers-in-law just got to take you say
that one more time i'ma shoot you in the
face are you funny it's gonna stick I'm
a hundred percent ready to be a
detective yeah you got man down what's
wrong with you my nerves is bad name
remember to say no vacation Pope is
moving contraband through the port
you're gonna help me get some hard
evidence on him get to the North hallway
and find out ain't nobody seen on TV
I'll get out of a window two thumbs up
lamb burger yeah I never had one of them
let me see what can't use it a cheese on
cello
yeah you can tell me and I'll get it
look I dropped the ball on that I won't
lie to you cuz you been here I've had a
nightclub shoot up 20 trespassing
complaints and a car blew up we implant
car bomb yeah but we did two other stuff
James you look like a damn marshmallow a
good detective knows how to blend in
with the locals oh yeah you blending all
right you're finally buying into the
concept of us being a family now I don't
even know if that's accurate the
partners James you protect each other
thanks big [ __ ] come on the fist I
definitely saved your life man don't go
too far now
can say me a little bit that time me a
man we the brothers-in-law not anymore
offer is off the table I stove st paul
st cola on the top runs into english it
come true on visaria shiz